and andrew haney as we said career start
number 90 the talented left-hander
fastball inside corner what a sequence
what a comeback he got strike one then
started swimming upstream then one
chance of fastball tonight
this man has had a really strong career
a 33 year old left-hander a career that
has seen him make 213 starts win 90
times home runs hits it hard to the
right side he is on the move one of the
fastest men in white tonight ohtani
hustling around hits second he's
thinking third chauhay in standing up a
triple
for that stride like a former injured
von white going from home to third so
gracefully and fast
here's mike trout with a chance to drive
in another
little roller
hustling down the line up johnny the
other line trout
one to nothing well going back to all
those little things the small things so
far
your mean mercedes his second major
league at back mercedes has his first
major league hit and it's the sox first
hit of this ball game and he is
absolutely amped over at first base he's
been waiting a long time for this 28
years old your mean mercedes climbing
through the miners and he is on base and
there's his baseball from albert well
it's it's really a great thing and that
baseball will live in the mercedes
household forever
madrigal into shallow left field here
comes upton he'll have to play it
so back to back two really pesky hitters
and if you ever love anything if you're
tony larussa you'll have a bottom of the
order that can do that
it's down it's ball four and now abreu
gets a crack at hiney here who he's
homered off of a couple times in his
career abreu with a drive out the other
way it is back and it is gone
that's a grand slam
that's home run number one
99. for jose abreu
don't walk luis robert again
look to see who's on deck if you choose
to go around one guy make sure it's not
a bray you standing over there that's do
up
andrew vaughn in search of his first
major league hit upstairs ball four
on the ground right hand side and
through it's past pujols and andrew
vaughan is going to go ahead and take
third base thank you very much so a
leadoff walk for vaughn
and then yeah shoots one through the
right side and the socks have runners at
first and third
adam eaton drives in another run and the
sox build it's now five to one as adam
trickles one by fletcher
hey welcome back adam eaton continues
driving in his third run
in just two nights and now you got
mercedes with a great chance to drive in
at least a run here
left side through he'll get at least one
run joe mcewing says come on down adam
eaton and he is
safe at the plate your maine mercedes
keep that baseball two it's seven to one
we told you about running on the
outfield of these angels and they run
out upton they'll run on fowler and they
will run on trout also although they
haven't had the opportunity tonight
mike trout's on the move again extra
bases in his future 27 takes to turn a
stand-up double as we walk albert pujols
up to the plate you've done as much as
he has when you've driven in 2101 you've
got to figure a bunch of them have won
games and
since 1974 no one has won more games
with rbis in that manner amazing albert
hits a high fly ball center field robert
going back to the wall
663 career home runs by the machine
albert bowles dead center field
this team
wants it this season albert
pumped up as he's crossed to play the
three-run home run fly to center field
grounded into a double play couple of
runners on for rendon anthony hits a
high fly ball to right racing toward the
corner and toward that line and the ball
drops
it gets by hayden
gonna get to that baseball
really good range he has played center
and he's played right in his career got
to that baseball unable to crowling in
the end though
[Applause]
that reminds me that breakup all the way
through the joey bottom remember that
one jose down in spring training oh
goodness i mean that's one of the
all-time greats as far as knowing the
strike zone he chases a pitch like that
it's like wow that was under the lights
just like this one
one and two the count
sinking fastball outside corner that's
strike three
look at that look going off the mound
too that is a look at the guy that loves
to compete he's got the stuff and he's
got the edge halo's just down one now
there's a sense of quiet in his system
that pitchers need
2-2 he busted him and he's got a strut
coming off the mound
oh boy
if he's going to throw it like this
steve
bullpen's going to be in good hands
in your major league debut if you go
three for three it's noteworthy and your
mean mercedes has done that
a little inside out job
and four hits for your mean mercedes now
that is a ridiculous
two strike hit
the bench really likes it he's a very
popular guy
it's one of those at bats where he hoped
albert learned something about movement
then right in her third gooby yep open
up those hips a little early they're
gonna
oh wow
tony respect
for pujols walking them
alberts
is walked
to represent
the go-ahead run
darren that's the first time i've seen
albert foles intensely walk in a long
time you're right
pujol smiling over at first liam
hendricks comes on to relieve this man
evan marshall who basically says i'm
sorry man
i was told to do that
all you're looking now if you're a
glacis is making contact
high fly ball well struck in the right
center field it is being tracked out
there by robert and the gold glover runs
it down boy the crowd had come out of
their seats
three in the batting order anderson
robert and abreu
tim loads this one up right center field
trout is back trout at the wall he leaps
and he has to duck this ball is up and
out of here and get the pasta ready tim
anderson goes deep it's 8-6 kim has
given the sox a much-needed insurance
run does he have any idea that he's on
the precipice of history i think he
might five for five your first start
you're mean to left field down the line
that is fair it's a five for five
couple more runs driven in yeah enjoy it
the precipice of history he has now been
crossed
oh donnie crushes it to deep right field
good
bye
shohei
going way back right center made the
adjustment and what a swing for ohtani
one two
he struck him out
and the white sox win 12-8 your mean
mercedes
he had one hit he kept the ball he got
an rbi he kept the ball he might as well
just pack up the entire game and keep
this for himself on a special night for
that young man